why don't you marry your kid's father
well you should I did oh okay oh you're
maybe not you're married you never know
okay well I just don't see your rings
exactly tell them about that he needs to
get that damn ring back I'm not married
okay so you're not married you know I
ain't gonna do that so it sounds like
he's working it sounds like it sounds
like he's working right he's got a job
so you're attracted to doing you two
kids with him he's cool I've got two
kids okay everybody he's got two other
kids yeah and before her before her okay
well you can't really change the past we
made the new kids with him right yeah so
why don't you why don't you get married
some people they need to change certain
things fast yeah yeah but you probably
need to change certain things I
definitely do yeah and so on and I have
changed them so I'm just I'm just
curious like why don't you guys work on
it together he needs to put more effort
in I can't work on it on myself well
maybe you need to put more effort in you
know putting them away yes but this is
the
it's like always it's like kind of an
arrogance like yeah
very young I'm very arrogant I can't
learn did you get married very young no
not Young
eight years you say you've been married
eight years I've been married for eight
years we've been together for eight
years
it's most important
he's not Zimbabwe no all right they'd be
they'd be married by that they'll be
married before no I would not marry
Zimbabwean sorry never but it sounds
like that would be better right yeah
like sorry
what's the alternative you know what I
mean it's like we it's like you either
stay together as a family or you bring
random men into your kids lives or they
bring random women correct I think both
ways you know
um so I'm just your situation is a you
know
for someone that this is zimbabweans I
would think that you're married and have
a husband that you know kids just with
you but it seems like you just ended up
in a situation just like the one before
like your circumstance your parents
circumstance exactly that's the thing I
didn't want that to happen to me but you
know when you feel like you're going
you're repeating the cycle it's like
whoa yeah why didn't you break the sack
with them how can I break the cycle I
can't work on it by myself you can only
do so much you can only do uh you know
responsible for your life since you I am
responsible for my life and I choose I
can pick and choose what I want to do
for my life right yeah you chose to
break the cycle yeah and I can I can
choose to make sure that my children
don't go through certain things right so
that's what I'm going to do if I feel
like certain things
you're gonna not put your kids through
certain things by putting them at
everything about statistical
disadvantage possibly I would rather
they have a better future so now they're
more like I agree they're more likely to
go to prison there
I've done hundreds of these shows like
100 like I've literally interviewed
hundreds of women every woman thinks
their kids the exception but every adult
you talk to will talk about how much it
hurt that their parents weren't together
of course it's gonna hide it will right
but that's what I'm saying like it's not
about you guys anymore and I'm not
really even talking about you personally
I don't know you guys situations but
like the whole point is you're dissing a
culture that that talks about keeping
families together they don't keep
families together they be you'll be I
Auntie is [__] that Uncle yeah that
Uncle different uncles no they do keep
they sleep with different uncles but
they all come together and say hi praise
the Lord I family yeah because we
understand that they understand that
personal life is personal life but
family life is more important yeah I
think people need to be realistic and be
like no it's not about being able it's
about being practical for your family if
you stay with your wife you say stay
with your partner your kids have a
better chance in life okay let me ask
you a question yeah let's go if you had
a daughter right now and she got married
man yeah and he is G in another next
woman would you ask her to stay if she's
married yeah you would ask her daughter
if she's married yes but why okay let's
say he's abusing her physically we just
ask her no that's abuse physically she
should go to the police and get the men
arrested
they protect their family that you
wouldn't sit back and take that you know
I'll predict myself that protects me
I'll protect my family yeah but if it's
just cheating without physical abuse she
made that choice to be with that person
yeah if they committed those vows in
front of God As a Christian I believe
then you should stay and work it out
she'll come to my my house we do
counseling between you two and we'll
work it out but what if he doesn't
change and well she she made that choice
to be with that person because as long
as he doesn't leave
modern women modern women pet guys that
cheat they pick guys that everybody
knows cheats they pick the guys with
kids with other women and then they're
surprised when he cheats what did you
think was going to happen every month
modern okay everyone no it's the men you
pick no it's all them no it's the menu
pick Not all men cheat it's like
okay why are the men that cheat picking
you
I don't know so it says more about you
than it does about them because there's
a lot of guys that don't cheat there's a
lot of guys that are loyal if they're
not picking you then you have to ask why
oh and then let's not forget they don't
they don't pick us we've got a selection
got an option plenty on the table and
yeah
okay if you say that so you you came
from a step parent household and you
made the choice to put your kids into a
stepparent household where's the step
parent you you say your partners two
other kids yeah yeah but I chose to you
I chose to accept them because I was
you're pretty much putting yourself in
the same situation you made that choice
I would imagine you coming from a choice
where he didn't work out between a step
parent you were doing one that for your
children but you made the choice to go
into that same situation and you didn't
even marry there's no commitment I mean
in a way I feel like there's nothing
wrong with accepting someone else's kids
there's nothing wrong with it there's
nothing wrong I know there's nothing
wrong with that but for you for your
situation just looking at where you're
coming from why would you make that
choice because my stepmom didn't love me
so I'm going to show love to another
child and I love them extremely
no matter what I always make sure
they're okay you know it's not the same
it is it is literally the same
you're telling me if you guys break up
and he picks someone new that you're
gonna have the same relationship with
the yeah they're still my children's
brother and sisters
no matter what I will always love those
kids yeah yeah but his point is that you
see the problems that came with that
situation and you still picked it so a
lot of times like as women We complain
about situations that we picked and then
we we get what's surprised that like
we're in the the same situation that we
picked
it's like like it's like a guy will
cheat on us when we're dating then we'll
have a kid and then whine about cheating
well then why why do you have a kid
um so do you expect us to get rid of the
child I'm not I'm not talking about you
guys I'm saying women in general will
pick men that cheat they'll know that
they cheat so oftentimes they'll get
cheated on when they're dating and then
they have a kid together and then whine
about the cheating but he cheated before
so why is it now a problem after you
have children so is that when you're not
the munchies or when you don't know the
munchies
I'm saying like women will go after
entertainers they'll go after rappers
athletes and then get I'm not talking
about you but they'll get shocked that
he cheats and but it's like you went for
that type of guy they'll go for the best
looking guy and then get surprised when
he cheats by even the best looking guys
even if you don't get with them they can
still cheat yeah that one of them and
they cheat they think most women one out
of three men are sexless so one out of
three men are either virgins or haven't
had sex in the past year you find 20
only 20 percent of men you guys find
attractive 80 of men you find ugly so if
women pick cheaters it's because they go
for a guy that's out of their league
because women that are fours fives and
sixes sleeps with eight nines and tens
maybe get a kid off of him and then he
cheats because they're not on the same
level
oh no I'm not talking about you
let me know
I'm not talking about you guys but I'm
saying like women find 80 of men is ugly
most men aren't getting laid like that
so if you're getting cheaters it's
because you pick cheaters
I agree I do
that's my weakness
the Little Adventures
so how is that like a Zimbabwean culture
oh my God
they drink
too they don't know how to hold the job
down they have that woman auntie auntie
auntie the sleeping with everybody
generalizing their own Nation once like
once they work on how much time have you
spent in Zimbabwe
um
like 10 10 years okay you spent 10 years
there yeah you came when you attend here
yeah that's cool enough and you knew a
lot about like cheating under the age of
10. when I was yeah when I saw quite a
lot that I will not even bring up no
that stuff
wow because I'm gonna get done for that
um no we don't want you getting cancer
I'm not bringing up gossip over here no
I'm gonna do that but
um yeah one even when I went back like I
was asking my grandma about certain
things like relationships and that and
you know because I Was preparing myself
for for marriage for the traditional
marriage and stuff and I was like okay
Grandma like you know if your man is
cheating on you what should you do hey
you have to stay wow if if the man is
beating you have to stay I was like oh
wow yes and you know they all gather
like in a group and they're telling you
oh you know you should do this for your
mind you should do this I was okay so
what did the man do for me they have
nothing to say
protecting
um if someone breaks into your house
someone's breaking the house and one of
the one that's gonna go outside to to be
the person because the man is not home
because out here cheating and drinking
true he ain't he ain't home you're
you're saying all the Zim men are
cheating
if you don't know about his involvements
yeah
we have we have that you know my own my
old my older I've had multiple people
work for me though from Zimbabwe there's
a stick
none of them were out no what's
happening right now is that the girls
are spreading the the loudest skills are
spreading this false narrative and
saying that Zimbabwe men are cheating
you just went home to your elders right
and what did they tell you if something
happens you stay you chose not to listen
to advice of your elders so who do you
go for for cancer in your life I've got
nobody that go to concert for in my life
I don't think that that's that's uh
anyone who lives on earth needs someone
to go for for guidance if you're just
living your life like this then you know
your actions do reflect I don't think we
can trust your opinion that was
involvement in that trash well you can
ask other women that are not as
importance
there's other cultures though I mean
there's no
you guys demonize traditional cultures
when traditional cultures have better
outcomes they have more children they
have happier women they have less STDs
they have less abortions like every
statistical outcome that you can look at
is better from traditional relationships
I grew on the abortion part yeah that
one that's the one I agree with there's
less abortions absolutely but the woman
is suffering from Silence
that's not true no I'm not saying all
I'm saying like there are some like you
know there are some that do suffer yeah
and there's some that you know the
relationships the women in the western
antidepressants they're fat the average
woman's like 165 pounds 170 pounds
that's fat
whoa I'm not part of this conversation
it's overweight
a lot of Zimbabwean women are fat
well I
was something that was gonna be really
I'm not even say anything
like that you have to you know why you
have to be respectful because let's look
at our family Yeah
by law in the celebrator the fitness
Zimbabwe men are cheating who are they
cheating with
iskenya women
okay so it's the women
right it's the women they're cheating
with the men right why is it the man why
is it not the women
you'd be surprised who they have to be
able to cheat with somebody
so why do you blame the men I blame the
men because of how I was raised like I
said in the beginning you know the way I
think of Tomorrow men is directly
reflected on how
um in my life have treated me and people
around me my other family members that's
basically it yeah
I'm not gonna run with that one then you
have to show me different show me
different show me something else
I'm communicating before like I do that
yeah I'm already showing the proof like
all right that's um yeah I see there
there is no waterproof though like I am
a Zimbabwe man and I do not cheat my
family this isn't lost Zimbabwe man
should I give should I give you a good
example
you the way you've been disagreeing with
everything I'm saying yeah that say
Zimbabwe man for you it is they will
never understand from another person's
point of view no it's not important it's
not a point of view if you're saying
something that I disagree with then as a
man uh actually as a Zimbabwe Man
actually we don't take women's thoughts
very seriously
wow he sounds like my uncle wow
yeah because you guys act out of emotion
a lot of the time and a lot of you now
westernized that's why I love this among
women men are not even marrying
Zimbabwean women anymore
but we're talking about the women that
are back home 25 of men cheat in your
age group
under 30
um and she approximately 10 of the time
and the girls cheat more at
approximately 15 percent
um half of male cheaters only cheat once
they're doing studies and women cheat
more
I'd argue if you if you no I agree gals
do cheat right but I just don't
understand why you have this like hatred
towards men that I've told you I have
gone through certain things but you said
you had issues with your stepmom too
yeah but I've had I've gone through
certain things but like there's shitty
men they're shitty women why do only men
get the brunt of it because I've never
been with a woman so I'm gonna talk face
on a man